the assassins are fighting for free will  and their main rivals are Templars and  Templars are trying to enhance human  kind through science I think Assassin's  Creed has a really deep concept an idea  which is going back into time and having  some sort of relationship with the  ancestor that's come before you the  overall journey of the film is through  the eyes of our protagonist the michael  fassbender's playing your past  he starts to learn that he comes from a  lineage of assassins he realizes the  true history of himself and he creates a  kind of revolution  to light  we are assassins  market is one of the greatest actors of  his generation and there's many other  strong characters in the film  the Assassin's Creed universe is  cinematic experience the action  sequences are massive  I just wanted to be an unbelievable  right  you have to show him who he really is